quite often in our industry a person
moves from one department to another a
film editor gets ambitious and becomes a
director a writer grows lazy and becomes
a studio head but never before the year
1952 the top-flight star turned into a
best-selling novelist with a screenplay
of her own in the making because
Hollywood regards her with great pride
asked her to make the writing Awards
tonight
miss Ruth Chatterton
I believe in the past that there's been
some confusion about the three Writing
Awards so I'm going to try to tell you a
little something about it first it seems
that the first goes to the right of the
best motion picture story this riser has
nothing to do with a screenplay say that
except for here's a germinating idea
shall we say original idea the
screenplay would never have been written
in fact it sir it's wrong father
relation the nominations for Best Motion
Picture story are bitter rice Lux films
Italian story by Josephine scientists
and carved lowly Sally the gunfighter
20th Century Fox story by William Bowers
and Andre the top mystery street
metro-goldwyn-mayer story by leonard
Spiegel gas panic in the streets 20th
Century Fox story by Edna and Edward and
hold and when when a comes marching home
20th Century Fox story by Saigon dead
the winners are Edna and Edward and
besides mr. mrs. M halt there are two
other husband and wives writing teams
among tonight's nominees these writers
are traveling short at this the first
nomination for either Edmund
there they are just coming to stage miss
mrs. I'm home
and let's come to this written
screenplay irrespective of its sauce
this writer took a novel to play or
motion picture story and developed it
into a screenplay
the nominees this year are all about Eve
20th Century Fox screenplay by Joseph
Jay Manuel's the asphalt jungle
metro-goldwyn-mayer screenplay by Ben
meadow and John Huston born yesterday
Columbia screenplay by Albert Mannheimer
Broken Arrow 20th Century Fox screenplay
by Michael blankfort and Farland bribed
Metro golden mayor screenplay by Francis
Goodrich and Albert Hackett Joanna
the winner is Joseph L
Grider all the great motion pictures of
1950 with the dog language
won the awards for a screenplay and
direction 1949 to remember far better to
three off lives
Michael wits is a writer who
now the third category is best story and
screenplay these nominees come from the
blank sheet of paper and they built it
into the script that you saw on screen
they are Adam's rib metro-goldwyn-mayer
story and screenplay by Ruth Gordon and
Garson Kanin caged wala brothers story
and screenplay by the jr. Kellogg and
Bernhard C shun tell the Len a Stanley
Kramer production United Artists story
and screenplay by called formal no way
out
20th Century Fox story and screenplay by
Joseph L mankiewicz and Lester Samuels
and Sunset Boulevard paramount story and
screenplay by child Brackett
Billy Wilder MDM Masum jr. now let's see
who's the winner
huh Charles Beckett Billy Wilder
the theme of China bracket producer
Billy Wilder directed won several wars
in 1925 for the very memorable film Lost
Weekend via Marshall